Whenever something looks interesting,  beautiful
there's a natural impulse to want to capture
and preserve it,
which means in this day and age
that we will likely to reach for our phones
and take picture.
Though this might seem like an ideal solution,
there is a big problem associated with it.
We're likely to be so busy taking the pictures
we forget to look at the world whose beauty and interest
prompted us to take a photograph in the first place.
These problems seem to be very much of today
a consequence of the tiny phones in our pockets.
But, they would notice right in at beginning of the history of photography
when the average camera was the size of a grandfather clock.
The first person to notice them was the english art critic John Ruskin
He was very impressed by cameras
at first,
but gradually he grew very suspicious of them
believing they blinded us of our surroundings
To try to correct this blindness
Ruskin recommended that all of us take up drawing
not with the view to becoming great artists
but simply because through the act of trying to recreate on paper
what we see in the world
we studied it in a way we never do
when we simply take a photograph
Summing up what he attempted to do
in four years of teaching and writing manuals on drawing
Ruskin wrote:
"Let two persons go out for a walk;"
"the one a good sketcher, the other having no taste of the kind."
"Let them go down a green lane."
"There will be a great difference in the scene as perceived by the two individuals."
"The one will see a lane and trees; he will perceive the trees to be green,"
"though he will think nothing about it;"
"he will see that the sun shines, and that it has a cheerful effect,"
"and that's all."
"But what will the sketcher see?"
"His eye is accustomed to search into the cause of beauty,"
"and penetrate the minutest parts of loveliness."
"He looks up, and observes how the showery and subdivided sunshine"
"comes sprinkled down among the gleaming leaves overhead,"
"till the air is filled with an emerald light,"
"he would see here and there a bough is seen emerging from the veil of leaves,"
"he would see the jewel brightness of the emerald moss,"
"and the variegated and fantastic lichens, "
"white and blue, purple and red, "
"all mellowed and mingled into a single garment of beauty."
"Then come the cavernous trunks, and the twisted roots"
"that grasp with their snake-like coils at the steep bank, "
"whose turfy slope is inlaid with flowers of a thousand dyes."
"Is not this worth seeing?"
"Yet if you are not a sketcher you will pass along the green lane,"
"and when you come home again, have nothing to say or to think about it,"
"but that you went down such and such a lane."